اول شيء هارد لك خساره المباراه اليوم
انطبائك عن المباراه بشكل عام يعني سيء
جدا وسهل وتدريب على الفاضي والله معسكر
على الفاضي لو قاعدين
مرتين اداه للسيد
كاس العالم طلعنا من بطوله كاس اسيا ان
شاء الله
توقف الدوري القطري لاشهر اثر اليوم
يعطيكم العافيه
كاس العالم
يعني مبروك الهولندي
وان شاء الله الناس ما قلت ضد هولندا نفوز
عليهم ان شاء الله توقعك الفوز على هولندا
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله باذن الله الله
يعطيك العافيه شكرا لكل الحقيقه كانت
مباراه جميله مع المنتخب السنغالي بطل
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
اليوم انا كنت في كنت في كاس العالم روسيا
كاس العالم في قطر تنظيم
همم دول العربيه بهذا التنظيم بارك الله
فيهم تحيه قطر وتحيه الشعوب العربيه
ونفتخر بها
واعتزاز وافتخر لنا في غصه عندك من
المنتخب الجزائري مش موجود معنا بهذه
البطوله هو همم شيء مؤسف صح في الحقيقه
لكن معلش فيه منتخبات عربيه تشرفنا نحنا
كل العرب في هالمنتخب المغربي في المنتخب
التونسي همم هو شيء مؤسف في الحقيقه كنا
نطلع اننا نكون هنا الله غالب
جاء المنتخب
التونسي يشرفونه وتشوفوا الجزائر ان شاء
الله في كاس افريقيا 2003
تصفيات كاس العالم
بامريكا ان شاء الله
سيء فالشوط الثاني يلعبوا يعني احسن
بالمنتخب القطري
اكرم عفيف لاحيب اكرم كل يوم ولا شويه
طيب
ولا عادي عادي يلا متعوضوها ان شاء الله
بكاس العالم الجايه بالبطولات الجايه ان
شاء الله هاردلك
لكن
نقول لهم هارد لك بس غير الكلمتين هذا لكن
كرتون تنظيم بامانه من ما توصل من المطار
المطار الدوحه لغايه ما توصل الملعب 100%